bill clinton peut-il être amené à
démissionner c'est possible après la
révélation d'une employée de la maison
blanche qui a qu'il aurait demandé de
faire un faux témoignage et de taire
leur liaison
le mouvement des chômeurs mécontents des
déclarations lionel jospin veut
continuer à faire pression sur le
gouvernement
la réponse de l'opposition philippe
seguin président du rpr invités ce
journal jean paul ii à cuba
le voyage historique a commencé les
critiques également contre le régime de
fidel castro
attention les femmes enceintes doivent
se méfier de certains solvants contenu
dans la peinture ou certains produits
domestiques il serait dangereux pour le
développement du foetus
une jeune fille en or roxana maracineanu
la première française championne du
monde de natation c'est aussi l'histoire
de l'intégration d'une famille roumaine
qui avaient fui la dictature de chaouchi
voilà monsieur bonsoir réélu
triomphalement il ya un an le président
américain bill clinton va t'il être
obligé de démissionner ou sera-t-il
destitué pour incitation à faux
témoignage pour mensonge donc comme le
fut en son temps
richard nixon la question est réellement
posé ce soir en effet la presse
américaine s'est emparé d'une nouvelle
affaire une liaison amoureuse entre le
président et une stagiaire de la maison
blanche qui lui aurait demandé de
dissimuler
alors qu'elle était elle-même interrogés
dans le cadre d'une autre affaire celle
de paula jones qui accuse également bill
clinton d'avoir voulu la forcer à une
relation sexuelle
deux affaires c'est beaucoup pour le
président qui se retrouve sur la
défensive obligé de s'expliquer devant
toute l'amérique
washington maryse bien un président
américain obligé de s'expliquer sur une
affaire sexuelle en pleine entrevue avec
yasser arafat
ces accusations sont fausses et je
demande à tout le monde de dire la
vérité
dès hier soir bill clinton était déjà
venu nié à la télévision à une heure de
grande écoute les accusations portées
contre lui
monsieur le président ce que c'est vrai
ce n'est pas vrai
après paula jones voici donc le nouveau
visage par qui le scandale arrive
monica lewinsky il y a trois ans elle
était stagiaire à la maison blanche
elle avait 21 ans selon certaines
vallées gassion elle aurait alors
entretenu pendant 18 mois une liaison
avec clinton clinton qui lui aurait
ensuite demandé de taire cette relation
est donc de mentir aux enquêteurs
chargés de la faire paula jones
selon cet analyste politique que nous
avons rencontré ce matin c'est cette
suspicion de subornation de témoin qui
est très grave
les gens se moquent de la vie sexuelle
du président mais il ne se moque pas du
fait qu'il ait pu utiliser sa position
pour faire pression sur quelqu'un le
procureur indépendant chargé de cette
nouvelle affaire le voici qu'est nextar
véritablement assailli ce matin par les
médias américains
selon l'hebdomadaire newsweek il serait
déjà en possession d'enregistrements de
conversations téléphoniques entre
levinsky et l'une de ses amies
ces enregistrements seraient
compromettants pour clinton
ces évacuations si bien sûr elles sont
prouvées sont graves et ses mains pour
le président parjure subornation de
témoin obstruction de la justice pour un
citoyen américain cela équivaut à cinq
ans de prison et pour le président des
états unis cela pourrait engager une
procédure de destitution fit bien sûr
ces accusations sont prouvées
il faut maintenant attendre les
conclusions du procureur indépendant
chargé de l'anc est pour nous français
ce type d'affaires politico sentimentale
prête d'abord à sourire étant donné
notre mentalité
aux états unis ça fait pas rire du tout
d'abord parce que l'amérique profonde
reste très puritaine même si elle se
prête à tous les excès et puis aux états
unis on vous croit sur parole et donc le
mensonge est impitoyablement punis de
nombreux politiciens promis au plus bel
avenir parfois on en fait la triste
expérience bernard lebrun en voiture
pour la série des grandes affaires
brisant deux grandes carrières et tout
d'abord celle ci il y à 28 ans sur les
rives de l'île de chappaquiddick en
cause ted kennedy sénateur et candidat
potentiel à la maison blanche dans sa
voiture est retrouvée noyée
l'ex secrétaire de bob kennedy ted n'a
prévenu la police que 10 heures après le
drame pourquoi soupçonnée d'adultère de
délit de fuite et de non assistance
il ne sera jamais condamné mais dans
l'amérique puritaine le soupçon suffit
edward kennedy
aujourd'hui grand père n'est toujours
que sénateur il a dû renoncer à
l'investiture démocrate en 1988
en raison de cette affaire
lui aussi il était grand favori pour la
maison blanche gary hart surnommé le
joker démocrates contre ronald reagan
et puis le 7 mai 1987 la presse à
scandale révèle et publie la
photographie de sa maîtresse un adultère
passé mais qui dans l'ordre moral
ambiant des années reagan suffira pour
que garou yard renonce à l'investiture
démocrate
des galons et des médailles cet amiral
de la navy en avait à revendre sur le
papier job board a été l'un des héros de
la guerre du vietnam
seulement voilà une enquête de newsweek
déjà a rétabli la cruelle vérité
deux de ces médailles n'étaient pas
avérés par des faits de guerre une
imposture est un mensonge dont l'amiral
ne se remettra pas plutôt qu'une
démission et le déshonneur
il se donne la mort après avoir reconnu
ses erreurs enfin dans cet immeuble de
la capitale débute en juin 1972 par un
simple cambriolage
la plus grande des affaires politiques
américaines au centre de la tempête du
watergate
le chef de l'état lui-même richard milos
nixon il faudra presque deux années
d'investigation de la presse de la
police et de la justice pour aboutir à
la première des missions de l'histoire
d'un président des états unis d'amérique
accusations centrale à laquelle richard
nixon n'a pu résister le mensonge en
france maintenant après la dernière
déclaration télévisée de lionel jospin
qui tout en acceptant l'augmentation de
certaines aides d'urgence ne veut pas
céder aux revendications essentielles
des chômeurs c'est à dire l'augmentation
des minima sociaux et bien les
différents mouvements et c'est de
maintenir la pression par des actions
limitées en nombre de participants mais
spectaculaire occupations de locaux du
cnpf à toulouse manifestation à lille et
puis pendant quelques heures un groupe a
envahi le siège du parti socialiste rue
de solférino à paris
l'évacuation s'est déroulée sans
incident notable après discussions avec
des responsables du parti socialiste qui
se trouvaient sur place à marseille
maintenant un groupe de militants et de
chômeurs s'est invité à un déjeuner
organisé à la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie jacques cardoze vincent des
ondes
la réponse des chômeurs marseillais à
jospin la voici une invitation forcé
sous les lambris de la chambre de
commerce d'amos visite surprise pour un
directeur qui attendaient d'autres
convives
le directeur nous a compris distille
contrairement au premier ministre
l'urgence de chômeurs s'est pas à l'an
2000 c'est maintenant c'est immédiat et
pas question d'interrompre un mouvement
qui dure maintenant depuis six semaines
c'est sans emploi multiplie les actions
jusqu'aux prochaines manifestations de
mardi prochain au prochain tournoi
car les arguments de lionel jospin n'ont
pas convaincu en particulier ceux
concernant les contraintes budgétaires
liées au relèvement des minima sociaux
celles ci vont relever les minima
sociaux sa cause soit 10 milliards ce
qu'il dit par ceux qui nous parlent se
concentrent 18 milliards c'est
exactement le montant des exonérations
vos patrons pour la sécu plus
d'occupations d'assedic mais une
occupation constante des esprits tel est
leur objectif
ici encore devant l'union patronale car
pour ces chômeurs ce qui se joue
actuellement c'est avant tout un choix
de société
il ya des jasp a indiqué hier soir
clairement ce qu'il pouvait faire et
seulement ce qu'ils pouvaient faire par
rapport aux demandes du mouvement des
chômeurs c'est à dire essentiellement
dans l'immédiat augmenter l'allocation
spécifique de solidarité pour les
chômeurs en fin de droits qui fera par
ailleurs l'objet d'un rattrapage
puisqu'elle n'a pas été augmenté depuis
1994 explication est leur embellie
depuis 1994 l'inflation c'est-à-dire le
coût de la vie a progressé lentement
mais sur cinq ans si l'on inclut les
prévisions pour l'année en cours ça fait
tout de même une hausse des prix de 8,15
% l'allocation spécifique de solidarité
elle n'a pas suivi cette baisse est
attribuée aux chômeurs en fin de droits
qui ont cotisé et donc travaillé au
moins cinq ans par le passé perçue par
cinq cent mille personnes
elle vient d'être revalorisé de 2% avec
effet rétroactif au 1er juillet 97
mais si l'état veut combler tout le
retard pris ces dernières années
il doit encore rattraper 6 6 %
d'inflation fin 98 au 2300 francs
actuels de la ss devraient donc
s'ajouter quelques 140 francs pour
porter l'allocation autour de 2440
francs au total sur 13 milliards de
francs actuellement pour la ss l'état
devrait accorder une rallonge environ
600 millions supplémentaires même si
matignon en avance pour l'heure aucun
chiffre
après l'assemblée après la télévision
lionel jospin a continué d'expliquer sa
politique aujourd'hui cette fois ci face
aux chefs d'entreprises à l'occasion du
forum de l'expansion devant un auditoire
majoritairement opposés aux 35 heures
par semaine il a expliqué en quoi
cette loi allait créer des emplois et
permettre de gagner la bataille du
chômage jean-paul chapelle et frédéric
parce qu une rencontre historique aucun
photographe ne veut manquer pour la
première fois depuis le début de leur
combat sur les 35 heures entre le
premier ministre et le patron des
patrons
cette poignée de main en public c'est le
premier signe d'apaisement dans le
conflit qui oppose gouvernement et
patronat veut dès ce matin le président
du cnpf a redit son hostilité de
principe à la loi sur les 35 heures mais
il a quand même apprécié l'intervention
de lionel jospin sur le problème des
chômeurs j'ai tout même et trouvait que
son ouverture très naître une société de
travail et non d'assistance assistanat
et d'une déclaration qui a
compte tenu des circonstances et du
milieu politique qu'est le sien reflète
un véritable courage et une véritable
vision et que je crois en tant
qu'entrepreneur nous apprécions ce
propos devant un parterre de patrons le
premier ministre lui est venu défendre
sa loi sur les 35 heures une des pistes
pour créer des emplois
mettant ainsi les chefs d'entreprise
devant leurs responsabilités
on peut pas dire l'emploi c'est les
entreprises et quand il s'agit des
chômeurs dire c'est l'état si l'emploi
c'est les entreprises si ce sont d'abord
les entreprises qui créent les emplois
il faut être logique ce sont elles aussi
sinon qu'ils créent les chômeurs en tout
cas qui n'offre pas suffisamment
d'emplois aux chômeurs un discours de
conviction qui vaut même au premier
ministre un mot de félicitations de la
part du patron des patrons
sans autres commentaires ernest antoine
seillière s'éclipse les autres chefs
d'entreprise restent sceptiques sur les
35 heures
j'avais des 35 heures et il n'a pas
l'air personne n'a l'air extrêmement
convaincu du succès qu un peu de lui
parce que j'ai envie de lutter contre le
chômage
il ya bien d'autres réformes
structurelles à faire que mes 35 heures
ce qui était déjà convaincu sont encore
plus convaincu aujourd'hui ce qui
n'était pas convaincu ou venant restent
avec leurs doutes
c'est mon cas faute d'être convaincu les
patrons vont attendre les modalités du
projet de loi débattu la semaine
prochaine à l'assemblée nationale
philippe séguin bonsoir on va voir si
vous vous avez été convaincu finalement
lionel jospin et hier soir il n'a pas
cédé aux revendications essentielles du
mouvement des chômeurs il a été assez
courageux mais surtout le monde 70
milliards à l'évidence le budget de
détails dans la capacité de faire face à
une dépense de ce type mais je sais
c'est pas parce qu'on appartient à
l'opposition qu'on raconte n'importe
quoi
pour ma part je me refuse à céder au
réflexe pavlovien et à la caricature et
je reconnais bien volontiers ici que ça
n'est pas monsieur jospin
contrairement à ce que j'entends parfois
qui est le seul responsable du niveau du
chômage en france le chômage il existait
avant monsieur jospin
bon cela étant dit le pronostic que je
formule sur les effets à venir de sa
politique parce que sa politique elle
n'a pas encore produit ses effets là
aussi il faut être équitable
le pronostic que je formule est un
pronostic malheureusement défaut pour
s'en aller
alors le premier ministre a pris cinq
engagements on voit bien que le coup de
pouce sera donné à l'allocation
spécifique de solidarité est ce que vous
pensez vous aussi qu'il faut revoir les
minima sociaux qu'il faut augmenter
aussi c'était le question est jusqu'où
pour ne pas toucher aux produits en
vérité le premier ministre a tourné
autour sans vraiment s'engager il faut
remettre tout le système à plat
nous sommes dans un système certains
chômeurs on dit d'ailleurs sur sur votre
antenne
manière très spontanée très vrai nous
sommes dans un système qui a été prévu
pour deux cent mille chômeurs je vous en
avons qu'un 16 ou 17 fois plus c'est un
système équipe bâtie en quelque sorte
sur le modèle de l'assurance automobile
on assure son emploi comme on assure son
automobile
le seul problème c'est qu'à 12 et 10 %
de la population active qui est au
chômage
ce qui veut dire que si on revient à
l'automobile que ça correspond à une
chance sur huit d'avoir un accident
quand on prend le volant matin c'est là
l'assurance automobile n'y résisterait
pas et bien l'assurance chômage qui
résiste pas non plus tout le monde
intervient tout mon intervient vous avez
donc là le système d'assurance chômage
unedic que vous avez l'état qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec la ss dans
l'immédiat j'avais les collectivités
locales vous avez les associations
caritatives
il faut tout remettre à plat parce que
le système actuel est un système qui est
à la fois inefficace et que l'on remet à
plat mais on relève les minima en
remettant à plat c'est pour relever les
minima pas parce qu'il ya la conjonction
avec la ministre a répondu je reconnais
bien volontiers qu'il est dans une
contradiction une étoile dans la contre
comme dans une contradiction entre les
espoirs 1 puis réaliste qu'il a
suscitées au kop sa campagne électorale
pas toujours à son corps défendant et
d'autre part les contraintes qu'il est
bien obligé de prendre en considération
ça c'est son problème je ne peux rien je
ne peux rien pour vous
un petit coup de pouce vous imaginez
déjà le soir je l'aï je vous dis que
pour ce qui nous concerne nous pensons
qu'il faut procéder à une réforme
structurelle et à titre principal
et sur ce point je le rejoins bien
volontiers il faut plutôt que de se
résigner à une société d'assistanat
faire en sorte que les gens soient
susceptibles d'avoir une activité et la
sortie par les était parlée par les 35
heures dont enfin le premier or pour lui
la création d'emplois c'est l'étrange
est opposée pourquoi pas estimé assez
lourd quoi
c'est pourquoi je disais tout à l'heure
son pronostic était défavorable le
premier ministre fonde toute sa
politique que sur deux éléments
le premier élément ce sont les emplois
aubry si je veux bien entendu le
deuxième élément ce sont les 35 heures
premier élément on peut plaindre des
emplois aubry par lebouc on veut il n'en
demeure pas moins que ce sont des
emplois de fonctionnaires des emplois de
fonctionnaires au rabais sans doute mais
des emplois de fonctionnaire quand même
tout le monde comprend bien que ce n'est
pas en augmentant le nombre des
fonctionnaires qu'on peut régler
problème du chômage
maintenant nous en sommes aux 35 heures
moi je ne suis pas opposé le mouvement
que je préside n'est pas opposé à la
diminution du temps du travail qui est
une opposition à ce général
nous sommes opposés à une réduction
uniforme et autoritaire du temps de
travail parce que nous pensons que ça
risque d'être contre productif il faut
négocier au cas par cas
entreprise par entreprise sans sur le
chiffre 6 ans il faudra sept cent mille
employés y croyez vous alors écoutez je
voudrais dire deux choses ce sujet la
première c'est que on y pense toujours
création d'emplois ne pense jamais de
diminution du nombre de chômeurs il faut
savoir que chaque année on créer deux
millions d'emplois dans ce pays plus ou
moins et on en détruit 2 millions et
qu'est ce qui est important c'est le
solde on parle jamais de ça or lorsque
les gens parlent comme le premier
ministre créer son emploi
les gens étaient a pas dix minutes en du
chômage ce sont deux choses radicalement
différente
ça prend deux choses que je veux dire la
deuxième moi j'ai lu
j'ai l'impression que je vais revenir à
mais les fameuses études mais d'abord
certaines d'entre elles émettent un
pronostic pessimiste et prévoit une
baisse de l'emploi du fait de
l'application des 35 heures ça on en
entend pas associé à paddy mission
première en tout cas en tout cas on n'en
a pas entendu parler par le premier
ministre et puis surtout surtout celles
qui sont favorables met deux préalables
mettre de préalable
le premier préalable c'est
l'introduction de la flexibilité dans
l'entreprise le deuxième préalable c'est
la baisse du salaire et je reviens mais
en calquant génial arriver dans les deux
catégories tôt en aucun cas y de
questions comme le laisse pourtant
entendre de poilus miss en fait qu elle
ne dément pas de travailler 35 heures
payées payées 39
or je le répète sur ces deux préalables
hier en tout cas le premier ministre et
est d'une discrétion absolue pour ne pas
dire un mutisme total
quand le premier ministre dit que les
chefs d'entreprise ont une
responsabilité sur ce que vous souffrez
faut ce montant vous disiez autres fois
où c'est parce qu'au niveau des autres
qu'ils doivent les ans évoluent les
entreprises ne sont pas comptables
vis-à-vis de la collectivité nationale
en termes d'emploi elles sont comptables
en termes d'accroissement de la richesse
nationale
c'est le gouvernement ce sont les
pouvoirs publics qui sont responsables
en termes d'activité ça ça lorsqu'une
entreprise pour survivre doit se
moderniser
douar robotisée ses installations doit
en conséquence supprimer des emplois
elle a le devoir de le faire faute de
quoi elle aura des difficultés parfois
même elle disparaîtra et du coup elle ne
remplira plus son devoir vis-à-vis des
festivités nationales toutes ces
histoires d'entreprise citoyenne c'est
d'un la rigole un pur et dur rien vu du
tout chut un discours extraordinairement
réaliste vous savez nous autres au
rassemblement pour la république parce
qu'il s'appelle toujours il a souri le
nom reste à jamais
il s'appelle toujours ainsi au
rassemblement pour la république depuis
sept mois j'entends dire qu'on me
reproche de ne pas assez parlé et c'est
une raison très simple depuis sept mois
nous nous sommes mis à travailler à
réfléchir
humblement et sérieusement aux solutions
à apporter à ce problème devant sur
lequel nous avons tous échoué
alors eh bien nous avons de réponse
première réponse c'est la baisse des
charges et la baisse de la fiscalité
quitte à revoir le périmètre
d'intervention de l'état et la deuxième
règle
la deuxième série de réponses parce que
ça ne suffira pas à assurer la pleine
activité
c'est la transformation du rmi en revenu
minimum d'activité c'est l'encouragement
c'est tout simplement de reconnaître que
lorsqu on apporte à quelqu'un qui est en
situation de chômage ou d'exclusion
un revenu ça n'est pas suffisant parce
que la dignité sociale la capacité
d'insertion
elle dépend aussi de la possibilité
d'exercer une activité alors je ne
conçois pas ne concevons pas l'activité
comme une contrepartie
mais comme une prestation supplémentaire
c'est pour terminer deux questions très
rapide d'abord vous avez beaucoup moqué
la majorité plurielle mais finalement
elle reste unie derrière premier
ministre le premier ministre cette expo
bulle hier c'était pour parler à qui
était ce pour parler aux chômeurs un
petit peu etait-ce pour parler à
l'opinion publique
beaucoup et est pour parler à sa propre
majorité énormément
en vérité c'est pour ça qu'il a parlé
qu'est ce qu'il a dit hier à titre
principal le premier ministre à sa
majorité
il lui a dit arrête il lui a dit arrêtez
de m'embêter arrêtez de vous divisez
parce qu'il va y avoir des élections
cantonales et régionales et nous
risquons ainsi d'avoir un très mauvais
résultat
il est inquiet moi aussi je suis inquiet
parce que comme il l'a dit comme il l'a
dit il est à la tête du gouvernement de
la france
il est à la tête du gouvernement
question il doit tenir ferme la barre or
actuellement qu'est ce que nous
constatons c'est qu'ils sont plusieurs à
se disputer pour tenir la barre ils
veulent pas tout ça les douaniers qui
vous aviez c'est ma dernière question
aussi cela si vous aviez à dire quelque
chose dans l'immédiat
mort qu'est ce que vous diriez de plus
que rien n'est juste pas nous leur
dirions que ce qui se passe nous
interpelle tous que ce qui se passe
c'est probablement positif que
l'important c'est probablement moins les
manifestations parce que
quantitativement se représente pas grand
chose l'événement c'est l'écho que ça
suscite ces gens j'espère que les gens
se souviendront de la réaction qui a été
la leur parce qu'il y aura un certain
nombre de décisions à prendre qui seront
des décisions difficiles qu'il faudra
assumer
il faudra qu'ils se rappellent après
quelle a été la réaction devant ces
situations de détresse de sa cloche chez
seguin je remercie le pape jean paul ii
a entamé son voyage historique dans
l'île de cuba
c'est la grande réconciliation entre
l'église catholique et le régime
communiste de fidel castro ce voyage est
également éminemment politique dans la
mesure où le leader cubain isolé depuis
près de 40 ans compte sur jean paul ii
pour briser l'embargo américain et les
premiers discours sur heroes porn de la
havane ont donné le ton éric meunier pas
d'accolades venu d'embrassades mais une
poignée de main franche longue et
chaleureuse pour accueillir jean paul 2
fidel castro a choisi de délaisser le
treillis révolutionnaire pour un sobre
costume sombre
voilà donc l'image que retiendra
l'histoire
dès l'aéroport la foule est là
hétéroclite elle mêle fidèles fervents
et militants communistes car cuba ne
cache pas le bénéfice politique escompté
et cette visite papale
dès le premier discours le ton est donné
le lider maximo dénonça génocide pour
parler de l'embargo américain imposé à
son pays
il y est encouragé par les déclarations
du pape un peu plus tôt dans l'avion
demandant aux états unis la levée des
sanctions et à cuba de s'ouvrir au monde
dans les rues de la havane sur le
passage de la papamobile
la ferveur populaire en corée spontanée
peut-être encadré c'est sûr par les
comités de défense de la révolution
le régime cubain reçoit le saint père
comme ils recevaient jadis les
militaires de l'ex bloc soviétique
pour sa première messe jean paul ii
s'est rendu aujourd'hui à santa clara la
ville où reposent les restes du che
guevara le leader emblématique de la
révolution cubaine le pape en a profité
pour dénoncer la situation économique
cette fois-ci catastrophique du pays
et le fossé qui sépare encore les
émigrés cubains 2 millions de ceux qui
sont restés au pays sur place alain
jeannot le cent mille habitants au coeur
de l'île de cuba santa clara paraissait
tout entière autour de l'hôtel de jean
paul ii pour voir et écouter le pas une
foule attentive pour un discours un peu
poil à gratter parlant des divisions
familiales provoquée par les migrations
de tant de cubains
il a déploré le cip les insatisfactions
pour raisons idéologiques qui selon lui
provoquent les migrations au même titre
que les 40 économique
la foule n'a pas pipé mot mais nombre de
catholiques ont sans doute acquiescé
même à santa chiara capital
révolutionnaire s'il en est c'est là en
effet qui est enterré che guevara c'est
là que le héros romantique de la
révolution cubaine a livré la bataille
décisive de la révolution celle qu'a
ouvert en faisant sauter ce train blindé
la route de la havane aux guérilleros
mais ce matin le mausolée n'avait aucun
visiteur et ceux qui passaient des
pressés
nouvel album je vais voir le pape à la
messe je l'admirais pour beaucoup de
raisons j'aime aussi l'aide chez vous
tue beaucoup le tce c'est un exemple
pour tous les cubains et le prr ossining
le pape et le tce pour les habitants de
santa clara qui se sont massés sur le
passage de jean paul ii pour ses
habitants des varices et catholiques de
naissance pour la plupart il n'y a pas
de contradiction
reste à savoir maintenant ce qu'il en
pense lui qui passe impassiblement
devants tôt dans l'avion qui l'amenait à
cuba jean paul ii a parlé de che guevara
c'est un homme at il dit qui aimait sans
doute les pauvres un signe qu'il peut
être pas de contradiction finalement
entrer mais le pape
en marge de ce voyage il y a donc
plusieurs milliers de cubains exilés aux
etats unis qui ont pu à cette occasion
retrouver leur pays leurs familles leurs
maisons leurs souvenirs bref leur vie
d'avant
sur place philippe gas c'est contre
l'avis de ses parents qui habitent new
york et qui ne veulent revenir qu'après
castro que raquel fille de réfugiés
cubains est venue voir le pape et
retrouver ses racines son oncle s'est
levé à 4h du matin ils habitent loin
c'est la première fois qu'elle voit
nolan son cousin la rencontre de deux
mondes dans un cadre d'hôtel il n'est
pas fait pour eux elle est empreinte
d'une extrême pudeur côté cuba est d'un
peu trop de sourires
côté américain il faudra du temps pour
se connaître
les photos de famille aide un peu
je n'ai pas vu car je n'ai jamais vu
mais on s'est parlé elle est
merveilleuse
l'oncle de raquel emprunter la brique
1956 d'un voisin le moteur à essence
d'origine a été changé pour un diesel ça
roule pas vite mais sa route elle a
décidé en dernière minute d'aller dans
le berceau de sa famille à madrid
72 km à l'ouest de la havane une heure
de route
elle n'est jamais venue par ici mais
connaît la maison par le récit de ses
parents la dernière fois qu'elle a vu sa
grand-tante c'était aux états unis il y
à bien longtemps
je n'ai pas vu depuis 12 ans aux états
unis en 85 la retenue est toujours là
mais cette fleurs cueillies pour elle
s'avoue bien des baisers un retour aux
sources où rien n'a bougé depuis 50 ans
elle nous montre la maison où sa mère a
grandi qui est devenu un magasin la
visite de l'americana est un événement
vient lui parler de ses parents de la
vie d'avant elle est ici et c'est
peut-être pour les habitants de madrid
la preuve que les temps changent algérie
pour la première fois le gouvernement
algérien donne un bilan les victimes des
actes de terrorisme de ces six dernières
années 26500 morts civils les forces de
l'ordre son gouvernement selon les
organisations humanitaires ce bilan
serait d'au moins 65 mille morts plus de
cent mille selon l'opposition algérie en
france la mairie front national de
vitrolles a décidé d'une mesure
spectaculaire dont elle sait qu'elle va
provoquer des réactions puisqu'il s'agit
d'accorder la préférence nationale pour
l'attribution d'une aide aux familles à
l'occasion d'une naissance une prime de
5000 francs mais il faut que l'un des
deux parents soient français ou
ressortissants l'union européenne
michael darmon didier leduc reportage
c'est un principe de gestion politique à
vitrolles crée à chaque fois l'événement
pour faire savoir que le programme du
front national s'applique ici jour après
jour la nouvelle mesure adoptée par
l'équipe maigret s'appelle allocations
municipales de naissance
depuis le 1er janvier une prime de 5000
francs est versée aux nouveaux parents
de vitrolles à condition qu'il soit pour
l'un d'entre eux au moins de nationalité
française ou européenne
c'est la préférence nationale avec la
préférence européenne nous sommes
partisans de cette hiérarchie des
préférences
parce que nous sommes conscients aussi
la partenaire une communauté de
civilisation une communauté de peuple
européen en abordant le thème sensible
de la préférence nationale
l'époux du maire de vitrolles a quelque
peu surpris l'opposition qui qualifie
cette décision d' illégale c'est une
mesure discriminatoire inacceptable qui
va encore une fois essayé de monter les
familles et les unes contre les autres
et pourrir un peu plus le climat
vitrolles qui n'a pas besoin mais à
l'heure de la sortie des écoles cet
après midi peu d'émotion parmi les
parents la nouvelle commence à être
connu et les réactions rappelle qu'ici
il y a un an un électeur sur deux a voté
catherine mégret ma foi déjà un
privilège et un peu et pourquoi pas une
de toute façon je pense que c'est une
très bonne solution
je pense que tous les enfants soient
égaux ils sont commence à faire des la
différence avec les enfants alors là là
c'est horrible pour bruno mégret
vitrolles est une base important dans sa
stratégie de conquête du front national
véritable patron de la ville chacune des
décisions du numéro deux du fn vise à
faire de vitrolles une ville clairement
dirigée par l'extrême droite
la régie des transports en commun de
saint-etienne a décidé de mettre en
place un suivi médical pour les
chauffeurs qui ont été agressés en effet
la direction de l'entreprise s'est rendu
compte que les employés concernés
devaient bénéficier d'un suivi
psychologique benoît gadret validé
jacquelin cela fait tout juste un an que
daniel a été agressé par quatre mineurs
des injures des menaces et pour finir
une pierre lancée au visage
sept points de suture deux mois d'arrêt
de travail et surtout un profond
traumatisme psychologique
moi j'ai un peu garder ça pour moi parce
que l'époque aérien qui était déjà en
place pour ça donc
je garde un peu moins
vous aviez pas envie d'en parler ou
si j'aurais eu envie d'en parler mais
j'en ai beaucoup parlé le jour même et
puis après oubli je suis sûr que vous
vous n'avez pas oublié absolument pas ce
sentiment d'abandon qui parfois nourri
des comportements d'autodéfense se
retrouve chez la plupart des chauffeurs
agressé l'absence d' écoute crée le
malaise alors il suffit d'un simple
incident pour paralyser l'entreprise
désormais les agents victimes de coups
seront suivis par cet homme et son
équipe à l'hôpital bellevue le
professeur debout reçoit chaque année
six à sept cents victimes d'agressions
de toutes sortes
peu à peu s'installe des difficultés des
malaises et à ce moment là évidemment il
faut que la victime puisse rencontrer
des professionnels des bénévoles qui
puisse l'aider à dépasser cette
situation de victime
il faut absolument que la victime sorte
de cette situation pro matic
daniel a repris le travail non sans
appréhension et pourtant saint-etienne
les chiffres des agressions dans les bus
sont plutôt à la baisse mais la pression
du quotidien les mots et les regards de
travers entretiennent le sentiment
d'insécurité
attention aux solvants chimiques
contenus dans des produits tels que la
peinture ou encore des produits
d'entretien ils peuvent comporter un
danger pour les femmes enceintes
notamment celles qui travaillent et qui
ont à manipuler donc de tels produits en
effet ces solvants ont peuvent avoir un
effet sur le foetus françoise valais
l'udc va chauffer
toute jeune maman sandrine retrouve son
poste de chimistes après un an d'absence
sandrine manipule des produits dangereux
et des nouvelles molécules dont on ne
connaît pas encore les effets sur
l'embryon dès les premiers jours de sa
grossesse elle a dû changer de travail
de la première visite d'embauché dans la
société
le médecin ou du travail à sensibiliser
à propos d'une grossesse futur ok elle
m'avait bien précisé que au cas où
j'étais enceinte de la prévenir
rapidement
bien souvent les femmes attendent le
troisième ou quatrième mois de grossesse
pour en parler à leur employeur elle
pense tous risques physiques les
derniers mois mais pour les produits
toxiques
il est trop tard leur effet s'exerce
surtout au cours des premières semaines
il est donc important d'évaluer les
risques
le médecin du travail à la connaissance
du poste de travail c'est lui qui doit
faire l'évaluation du risque
mais son rôle essentiel c'est d'informer
les femmes de les sensibiliser
mais les femmes ne sont pas toujours
suivis par un médecin du travail
artisans professions libérales
elles sont nombreuses à utiliser des
substances toxiques le risque chimique
existe même à la maison produits
ménagers solvants dans les peintures à
l'eau par exemple monde pense en
première intention à malformations ce ne
sont pas les seuls vous avez les
avortements deux types l'avortement
précoce puisque la grossesse n'est même
pas connu reconnu et puis l'avortement
dûment authentifiés derrière vous pouvez
avoir le retard de croissance dans le
ventre de la mère et vous aurez ensuite
la prématurité voir l'amorcé talent ou
la mort à la naissance
les femmes enceintes doivent donc
redoubler de vigilance et surtout lire
les étiquettes des produits qu'elle
manipule insolite visiter le nid d'aigle
d'hitler à berchtesgaden c'est une
nouvelle destination touristique en
allemagne à la frontière autrichienne
dans ce haut lieu du nazisme ou le
chancelier et mettent à se reposer a
invité ses amis alors mise en valeur de
ce site et la création d'un centre de
documentation accablant pour les nazis
provoque des réactions indignées cette
fois ci de la part des groupes néo nazis
olivier werner la visite des abris
antiaériens sans un mot d'explication
c'est tout ce que l'on propose
aujourd'hui aux nombreux touristes qui
passent par berchtesgaden
il est vrai que les graffitis sur les
murs parlent d'eux mêmes mais ici dans
huit mois au coeur même de ce sanctuaire
du troisième reich
l'ouverture d'un centre de documentation
constituera un véritable événement les
néonazis ont déjà inauguré le bâtiment à
leur manière un lieu de mémoire qui rqra
le régime nazi et le low cost à 50
mètres sous terre
on pénètre dans des abris luxueux avec
d'énormes coffre fort le 5 mai 1945 les
troupes françaises américaines ont fait
ici l'une de leurs plus belles
découvertes
une centaine de chambres en sous sol
près de 200 en surface cet hôtel hitler
l'avait réservée pour ses admirateurs
qui pouvaient ainsi espérer approcher le
führer c'était l'endroit préféré
d'hitler
l'hôtel est à vendre aujourd'hui
quelques centaines de mètres plus haut
hitler avait sa maison est une immense
terrasse de l'envoyer l'autriche toute
proche eva braun jouait les duchesses
l'été à berchtesgaden
hitler s'amusait parfois devant ses
invités prestigieux et si goebbels
ministre de la propagande qui organisait
les réceptions et qui surtout diffuser
les images
et masirah dieu sur fond de paysages
merveilleux pour hbo belz berchtesgaden
c'était le rêve sa propre maison
hitler l'a dessinée de sa main avec
cette salle d'audience et son plafond à
caissons agrandi trois fois aménagé avec
les plus beaux matériaux de l'époque les
architectes devait exécuter les idées
les plus folles d'hitler en avril 45 sa
garde rapprochée n'a rien pu faire
berchtesgaden bombardé la maison
d'hitler a été grâce des cassettes de
propagande vendus sur place permettent
d'apprécier le nid d'aigle
le point le plus haut de la région d'où
est claire a eu l'idée d'envahir la
pologne et d'ouvrir les camps de
concentration mais curieusement le nid
d'aigle perché ici à 1834 mètres
d'altitude est épargné aujourd'hui il
fait office de refuge hôtel restaurant
où toutes les traces des différents
passages d'hitler ont été effacés sport
tennis internationaux d'australie ça va
toujours très fort pour les français ils
sont dix à être qualifié pour les
seizièmes de finale les derniers en date
raoult x qui a battu l'américain ne
change pas n'importe quoi en trois sets
vite fait
escudé qui a sorti lui le brésilien
gustavo kuerten vainqueur de roland
garros belle victoire discuter pour lui
que ça dure
elle est devenue célèbre en deux minutes
11 secondes samedi dernier à perth en
australie aux championnats du monde de
natation son nom roxana maracineanu pour
l'instant la jeune fille fait fructifier
sa médaille d'or du 200 mètres d'eau
dans les piscines australienne mais tous
les jours et l'appel mulhouse et ses
parents au téléphone
la réussite de roxana c'est aussi celle
de l'intégration d'une famille qui avait
fui la roumanie et la dictature de
chaouchi ce reportage alexandre car
alors papa à lui ferment
il ya tout le monde du cycle est atteint
et appelé le monde
on rentre j'arrive au moment là on est
encore dans la piscine
nous avons fait la fête
nous avons au bout des champagnes un
bonheur simple comme un coup de fil un
appel du bout du monde un appel d'une
championne à ses parents roxana
maracineanu est une nageuse d'exception
le 18 janvier dernier elle est même
devenue la première championne du monde
de l'histoire de la natation française
c'était sur 200 m dos à perth en
australie pour que la france décroche ce
titre mondial il aura fallu le destin
exceptionnel de roxana oksana la petite
réfugiés roumaine arrivée en france à
l'âge de 9 ans pour fuir le régime de
ceausescu
et puis quand le moment était venu de
partir
mon père a demandé au gouvernement
comment la latéralisation pour venir en
voiture comme ça par le roi pour faire
du tourisme qui en fait on s'est arrêté
dès qu'on a l'occasion
la nuque tout est compliqué pour la
famille maracineanu c'est à mulhouse en
alsace qu'une nouvelle vie a commencé
jj ponctuée par la fulgurante ascension
de la fille prodige jusqu'à lettres en
ses créations une consécration qui
valait bien une lettre pour une famille
qui aime à se présenter comme championne
de l'intégration donner le maximum moi
aussi au niveau professionnel
donc c'est un maximum ça veut dire que
la zad blade pierre d notre présence ici
fier comme une mère de son enfant fier
d'une championne française qui n'oublie
pas pour autant ses origines ne serait
plus vraiment
c'est
il aura fallu une belle histoire pour
que la natation française décroche son
premier titre mondial
une histoire de bohème comment raconte
si souvent le sport tricolore
si vous êtes amateur de séries tv
américaines un nouveau héros vient de
disparaître
jack lord qui pendant 12 ans incarne al
policiers héros de hawaï police d'état
le voici sur ces images diffusées dans
plus de 80 pays pendant une dizaine
d'années avant de quitter le rappel des
principaux titres de ce jeudi d'abord
bill clinton peut-il être amené à
démissionner c'est possible après la
révélation d'une employée de la maison
blanche avec qui il a eu une liaison et
qui lui aurait demandé de taire le
mouvement des chômeurs mécontents des
déclarations d'un jospin philippe séguin
a trouvé lionel jospin courageux mais il
a tort dans sa loi sur les 35 heures par
semaine
et puis jean paul ii à cuba voyage
historique qui a commencé avec des
critiques contre le régime de fidel
castro dans un instant la météo sophie
davant pour un roe de valérie maurice
20h50
l'envoyé spécial magazine de la
rédaction paul nahon et bernard benyamin
demain matin françoise laborde recevra
dans les 4 vérités à 7h50
monseigneur gaillot voilà je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur notre
chaîne demain ici même vous retrouverez
des attriste sean bell conscient
je vous retrouve dans